good morning believe nation today's
message is love what you do over to you
Rihanna
I always loved music I always loved it
and then I will start singing along and
before you knew it I wanted to be that
person so bad that I would lip sing and
dance or look in the mirror perform for
my friends or cousins and I just always
knew I just always knew one day I'm
gonna be doing this I knew I loved this
message because you look at the most
successful people in the world look at
people who've achieved the top and
whatever field they're at they love what
they do it's not just about reaching an
end goal but they love the process they
love the activity I love making YouTube
videos I love helping entrepreneurs I
think some people know you know Rihanna
knew from an early age he knew this is
what she wanted to do and congrats to
her for having the conviction to follow
through on that goal a lot of people
don't know a lot of people don't know
what they wanted to do I didn't know I
thought I wanted to be a banker you look
at my high school yearbook I've told
this story a number of times I wanted to
be a banker and I think you owe it to
yourself to explore because you could be
Rihanna at something you have Rihanna
level genius talent at something and
maybe singing it may be something
totally else you know for me I can't
sing the Rihanna no we're close growing
up I always saw the world differently
than others my teachers they didn't
understand me they said I had problems
but you need to find the thing that you
can be Rihanna level at so if you know
what you want to do you have to have the
conviction to follow through you have to
have the courage to stay on that path
even when the people around you tell you
you're crazy or you tell yourself you're
crazy or you have no visual signs yet of
success you have to stay on that path if
you love what you do and trust that it's
gonna work out part of belief for me is
trusting that it will work out
eventually even though it's only
darkness around you it is going to work
out if you continue to hone your craft
you continue to try to provide value for
people sometimes it happens quickly
sometimes it takes a long time for you
to get there if you don't know what you
do then stop settling don't settle for
the life that you have with the job that
you have with the business that you have
don't settle for just mediocrity don't
settle for just okay have the courage to
say I don't know what I want to do but I
know it's not this I know what I'm doing
right now I'm not having Rihanna level
impact and talent in so I need to leave
that and go explore other things and
doesn't mean you leave 100% right you
can explore on the side you don't have
to burn your bridges you don't have to
go into your boss and flip his desk over
and freak out right you don't have to do
that but you need to at least be
spending some time exploring you need to
spend some time to discover what it is
that you love because until you find
that you're never going to be happy
you're never gonna have the impact that
you can have and you're constantly going
to be doing things that are beneath your
level of talent and genius so go find
the thing that you can be running a
level at so the question today today is
I'm curious have you found what you
truly love to do yet have you really
found that super curious to find out
leave in comments below and I will join
in the discussion I don't so love to
give a quick shout out to Richard ya
Guti love or you got a love for
pre-order in my book thank you man that
means a lot to me for your chance to get
a shout out in a future video make sure
you pick up a copy of the book and email
us your receipt thank you guys so much
for watching have an amazing day
continue to believe or whatever your one
word is and I'll see you again tomorrow
morning for another shot of espresso